[Music]
product Scorpio talk because digital
foundry releases specs was it last week
yeah uh yeah as last week there's
there's that stream right and you guys
came in early to cover it or at least it
released early so and then pete
obviously like follows this kind of
hardware stuff pretty frequently yeah um
Kelly you a hardware person I built my
own pc that's bling that's what's more
than what more than what I'm saying yeah
alright cool so let me to start with the
basics Michael hit me with the specs
what is this like so well I'm not gonna
run down like all the specs cuz that can
get you every single one of them okay
guys getting it well as a core cpu two
point three gigahertz based on jaguar
architecture its improved this time they
actually do have six teraflops for in
layman's terms teraflops is just a
measurement of how powerful something is
graphically and it seems that they're
actually hitting that they have 12 gigs
of RAM on that eight that caped games
for for the dashboard so and I'm
anticipating that that that's actually
going to be a pretty big deal because
you know getting in and out of the xbox
dashboard it can kind of be a pain so if
you dedicate ram to that specifically I
imagine it would be smoother I sure hope
so because that interfaces can be rough
sometimes so that's and it's gonna have
a vapor chamber cooling be vaping in
your this thing in face now but vapor
chamber chamber cooling is actually a
pretty eat I've heard it's an efficient
way of keeping your your stuff pretty
cool man yeah without having too many
fans going as well as other passive
solution quieter yeah shouldn't be like
a jet engine correct yeah so those are
kind of the basic specs but yeah you can
check all that information out on
several websites but the main thing
though for me was that Forza tech demo
that they showed off so they were
showing off native 4k for a console
which i think is pretty impressive it
was running 60 frames per second but
although you'll see a lot in headlines
Oh 4k 60fps Oh Scorpio is going to be
like so dope but you know it's just the
Forza tech demo no other games are going
to perform differently so you know
saying that everything's gonna be 60 FPS
is
that's probably more I'm willing to bet
it's not gonna be true and well and this
is also like the forces of games are
hard surface 3 models that are not as
like diverse in terms of textures and
all the different layers of textures
that go into handling lighting as
something like an organic model would be
like a scene full of hundreds of humans
right right one car is very different
got a lot of it yeah they did a in the
demo they max out how many cars they
could put on there to kind of stress
test it a little bit but you know cars
don't animate also and they don't
explode and you know there's not a
transformer not enforce it they do not a
far is it at all but uh so in terms of
like particle effects and
post-processing you know it's an easy
easy comparison to make but back in the
day when like a ps4 pro is on the
horizon and then the Scorpio is still
kind of this nebulous thing you know
Microsoft kept saying it was going to be
more powerful that's easy comparison but
how does it compare to the ps4 pro at
least from these the specs we've gotten
well it's about forty percent it's
supposed to be about forty forty three
percent more powerful than the ps4 pro
so then that was the expectation that it
was going to be more powerful than the
ps4 pro so there's no surprise there and
you know doing that because ps4 Pro
doesn't do native 4k I don't believe or
there may be some cases doesn't have a
workaround to a power couple games or
other games that will scale like it'll
render at a slightly lower resolution
and bump it up yeah okay yeah so if
Scorpio says they're going to do native
okay they obviously have to be more
powerful than the ps4 pro another thing
is what compromises are they going to
have to make for future games because as
games go on there going to be more and
more demanding so if you want to keep up
with 4k you're going to have to scale
back other things like maybe draw a
distance or you know post-processing or
texture quality but it is more powerful
than the ps4 pro what does it mean for
um like cloud kind of when they were
running off the cloud when they were
showing off crackdown 3 at first does
that does the Scorpio mean anything for
that like advancing that because you do
that off a normal xbox one right now
that was a couple years ago I mean the
cloud stuff is totally independent from
the console in terms of processing power
right maybe they could try to do like a
glimmer of
they were showcasing with crackdown 2
which was literally fully destructible
environments in a multiplayer scenario
which is really crazy um yeah the whole
like cityscape was just toppling over
yeah like not I mean and not in a way
that was pre animatedly it was all
dynamic physics driven stuff which is
nuts like a little every little bit in
piece of a building animating what about
if you were to compare this to like a I
don't know to a nice pc how would this
compare well Jimmy's actually going to
be working on that is trying to build a
pc that's similar to the power of x box
score for project scorpio right now i
would say the well in terms of teraflops
the RX 480 the radeon r x 480 is about
5.8 teraflops so i guess there's there's
no one-to-one comparison that you can
make in terms a pc hardware but if you
couldn't do a rough estimate the RX 480
I've heard people saying that this can
be as powerful as at GTX 1070 and that's
a really good graphics card that you can
do 4k in some instances with like medium
to high settings so if it's if it's in
that range then you know it's a pretty
beefy console we don't know the price
yet but what would a comparable pc like
what would that cost to build um
especially with that kind of graphics
card I think you could hit that with fur
like 700 to 800 bucks just on the pc
alone if you don't factor and uh well
because then operating system is going
to cost a hundred dollars so if you
don't consider that like hardware alone
probably about seven hundred monitor and
keyboard and all that but yeah it's
actual guts yeah probably about 700 to
800 bucks to get segue I was actually
gonna kind of ask go around the table we
do have a gamespot QA up on the site
about what like a bunch of our editors
and a couple producers think about the
price what the price will be for the
Scorpio is it's not announced yet and
then I just wanted to ask you guys
Michael what do you think it'll be I
said it's going to be 500 bucks because
if it's any cheaper that hardware is
actually like pretty damn dope so I
imagine it's going to be expensive to
make so if you're gonna if it's going to
be less than 500 bucks I would be
surprised that would be sweet because
then that's you know cheaper for
everyone else to buy but I can't see it
being any higher than 500 buck
because then like who that was gonna buy
it like I could get a you know what come
holiday season ps4 pros are probably
going to be I'm not saying that they are
going to but it's likely that they'll
have like fifty dollar price cut so
around three hundred fifty dollars
compared to this Scorpio that would be
five hundred dollars you know even that
thinking about that is a pretty wide gap
in thinking all what console do I want
to buy so I can't see it any higher than
500 bucks but this is pretty powerful
hardware in the console space so that's
what I'm saying I'm saying Kelly what
about you yeah I imagine it would be
around 500 um I think it was Jimmy in
that QA was talking about the point of
entry for ps3 was so high initially but
the value of what you were getting was
actually really good like it was the
cheapest blu-ray player you could get at
the time and so I think just learning
from that consumers not understanding
that right away at face value I don't
think it would go higher than that just
because even if the valley even if a
comparable comparable pc would be seven
or eight hundred dollars and this was if
this was 500 people don't necessarily
know that and so i think it would be
hard to convince people to pick this
over say a ps4 pro if it went any higher
than 500 p what about you i don't know i
think the bigger question rather than
the hardware is what Microsoft is really
trying to do with this product so right
now the xbox one s is 250 in my mind
there's absolutely no way they're going
to double that price for a system that
plays the exact same games because then
you're immediately saying your customers
like well I don't know what that message
would be like you're trying to retain
like the highest the most enthusiastic
people but Microsoft is not doing so hot
in terms of retaining their audience
we're putting out great game so what are
they gonna plan this system right but if
you go up against the ps4 pro and
they're trying to win that audience back
hey if they can go four hundred and
match that price they might convince
people and tip them over with the value
that Callie was talking about and it's
fair if you look in the past like a
history of gaming consoles companies
sell systems at a loss all the time yeah
so even if this costs four hundred
dollars for them to make they will lose
that money to get consumers back because
they make far more on software sales and
they ever do on hardware yeah Jim soon
foreigner
yeah I mean they haven't ps4 pro has how
many games that have like better
versions on ps4 pro I mean one of the
first ones was titanfall 2 and I know
uncharted for the love the original last
of us they were updating Naughty Dog
updated those for the ps4 pro but like
you said it's not immediately apparent
aside from upgraded hardware what the
Scorpio is wider would I've got eyes
you've got to buy a new TV yeah I mean
what what point is that 4k gaming if you
don't have a 4k TV right so well let me
tell you about that it just really quick
so I think that for me this is kind of
important for people who are still on
1080p tvs is that Scorpio is going to
super sample your game so you'll get
like that so super sampling is type of
anti-aliasing so it'll take a 4k image
4k image and it'll shrink it down to
1080p so you'll get like sort of that
pixel density that you would get in 4k
and then you kind of convince it without
a little sliding anti-aliasing yeah so
it's gonna look super fine so that's
what you can get like there's like I'm
not gonna get a Scorpio hook it up to a
1080p TV and like get no benefit so no
is that oh of course yeah but I think if
they're gonna sell this thing for 500
bucks like I think that that's really
speaking to an audience that is the
high-end enthusiast and they want to get
the most out of this thing the most that
they can for their five hundred dollars
if they're just getting a little bit
better you know not quite anti-aliasing
but anti-aliasing like effect is that
enough to spend another two hundred
fifty dollars uh yeah siano that's the
catch that's what that's what I'm not
sure about yeah at this point Michael
does it seem appealing to you do you
think you're gonna buy one day 14 wolf
for me personally no because I don't
really play anything on xbox man like
everything that I want to play is youth
on ps4 and for multi platts i play on PC
because I have a fairly decent pc but if
I was huh if I didn't have a console or
this generation of consoles I still
don't know if I would I still don't know
if I would make that jump just because
of exclusives but for my tastes I'm as
much as I am into pc hardware and like
the most swagged out pcs that we can
like build I mean I don't care all that
much about graphical fidelity
when I think about the games that are
important to me they're all like
independent games like almost retro
style 16-bit so yeah all those all that
graphical fidelity for undertale you
know yeah yeah it's like one of my
favorite games of all time but you know
show me some games man like that's what
I want and I'm I'm hoping that you know
Microsoft makes a big splash in e3 and
shows us gives us a reason to like
people who are on the fence about
getting an x bar interested in Scorpio
but still don't need that reason to buy
one you know show me something I eat 30
like give me a reason to buy that yeah
it's like as big of a halo fan as I am
halo 6 might not be enough to push me
over the edge when they if they show it
at e3 but you know you don't think
they're going to know I'm really know
that would be that would be like yeah
the worst thing they could do is to hang
their hat on a new halo yeah just all
this new console that would just show
how incredibly short-sighted this
company is being because that's not
anything special that's not the sort of
thing that's going to get people to
rally around a console when it hasn't
worked this generation yet especially
considering scale bounds recent
cancellation yeah that was an exclusive
crackdown 3 we don't know what the hell
is going on right it really especially
with scalebound it was like it was an IP
that was like knew it was something like
really experimental and exciting when
you look at games like me persona and
near aren't new but when you look at
what those games are doing it's so
different than the status quo yeah so if
it's just for zoo and halo I could care
less yeah i do want to i sent John look
a few screenshots earlier we they did
just release dev kit prototype images of
the Scorpio it looks pretty good see if
you can throw those up now but they look
it looks kind of sort of like and it
looks pretty similar to an S in the
sense that you know it's the pretty
sleek white thing but instead of the I
don't know what these is the I don't
know Michael what are we looking at here
and in terms of it look at an Xbox man
well I think that it kind of looks like
because that's original xbox one two
that's right so I imagine it would be
the same size got like that all that
dope hardware in there but I mean I
think those me and Jimmy were looking at
this and like are those five buttons on
the left line what are they for but yeah
they're like those are LEDs for like Oh
player 1 through 4 connected oh and then
is that a disc tray underneath it
yeah so I don't think those are buttons
and I think those are LED lights
actually can maybe see look at you this
evening it could be buttons to switch
between different like builds of games
like I've seen Sony like ps3 and ps4 dev
kits that have like similar sort of
things on them I don't know what they do
is I haven't used them but those were
buttons on the old kits for other
systems I saw maybe so to help swish
things fast okay like are you saying
maybe those won't be on the final oh no
no I don't think those will be right at
all yeah cool uh it's an xbox looks like
on xbox those it's a nice-looking system
yeah you know I Microsoft just needs a
better selection of games that is the
biggest hang-up right now yeah I mean
told him the reason I still like I cuz I
was Xbox last generation primarily and I
play multiplayer games with my dad on
xbox like that shirt I mean the reason
I'm still on xbox ever because like I
think the common complaint is like
there's not enough games but as far as
multi-platinum stuff like if all of your
friends are on xbox you're going to
stray on xbox I don't think that's a
knife of a reason to go to Scorpio right
you can spend tuner bucks in a
refurbished xbox one exactly yeah cool
uh well yeah if anybody wants to know
more in depth in info about the xbox one
score or the project Scorpio we have six
things you should know about Scorpio
which you wrote Michael yeah I wrote
them i voiced it yeah press up on
gamespot we kind of were doing some
comparisons to you know ps4 pro and PC
more in-depth you can go see on gamespot
and let us know what you think in the
comments and for those just joining us
we do have the twitch and YouTube and
GameSpot chats up here in the studio see
what you saying but yeah so let us know
you think about project Scorpio
[Music]